I'm 28 and I've never had one that's too
many years without padmi okay being
Chinese and Vietnamese American I grew
up eating venom you sandwiches or bun
made the thing is I could never decide
which one is my favorite
cuz they're all so good I got a few my
co-workers here they're gonna rate the
sandwiches from a one to five and we're
gonna calculate the total oh yes there's
a weird thing going on in here is this
ham lady in the trance time yeah perfect
drunk food they're kind of doing kind of
like jello we're what color is that the
meats a little ambiguous so that kind of
throws me off if you just close your
eyes it tastes pretty good it's a little
creamy almost like a pate I know I'm
assuming this is like Vietnamese baloney
is it spam I don't know what I'm eating
but I can't stop eating
give me another bite one out of five I
give that up on one I'm giving it to
mainly because of like the way they made
it three and a half stars I have nothing
to compare it to so I'm going to say
three all wrong work I think four bar
baby till I'm their first I'm assuming
I'm gonna have better wait this is
literally the same thing now grilled
chicken bond me hey I love grilled
chicken so this actually looks like
chicken oh [ __ ] yeah and it's so savory
I love it I'm mostly happy which are
happy sandwich
it is like chicken satay that's like
exactly what it is that's chicken is
bomb a half hmm you knew in this turning
looks like the chicken that comes on
stick maybe I'm just not a picky eater
but this is a really delicious Wow
there's one's a little more fitfully
they all have the same amount of pickle
it's a little smoky it's almost like han
doori chicken mmm we're sort of like
kissing someone who's happy crying tears
because it's a sweet moment but it's
also savory and salty the best time to
kiss a person they're happy was the
score I'm gonna give it a 4/5 4.53
I give it a three - it's just nothing
special slightly better than
I'm gonna give it a pour I'll say it
like four as well I'm team chicken
mm-hmm
grilled pork oh this is gonna be [ __ ]
I love eating pork hey this one looks
like the other one what I know they give
on mm-hmm it's a partier now everything
about it though I like the carrot you
can come right like the crunch so many
good flavors oh my god kind of Korean
barbecue ish really well-seasoned smoky
I see hanging dark the meat itself is
aromatic and everything else is also
aromatic to the best one so far the meat
absorbed all the seasoning and flavor
this one's my favorite winner yeah yeah
there was no party it'd be a fiesta I
want to leave room to gross I'm gonna
give it a four point seven
I'm gonna go to four three or four F
words that's five that's ten
I like the smile on your face when you
put the plate down like that that's like
fish is the sardines
yeah sardines cane why I don't want to
eat sardines it's very deceiving because
it looks likes meat I guess it is meat
it's fish meat my hair for 1300 Wow oh
gosh I don't like at all
give me the sardine sandwich make it too
can you not tell it's fish it's so busy
mm-hmm
it tastes like the fish sauce that you
dip stuff in but it's just the fish I
want the other one back if you didn't
tell me that was fish I wasn't known
imperative kissing someone who's sad
crying but you don't love that person
this sandwich tastes to me like when
you're learning how to ride a bike and
you think you got it but then you
stumble over and you fall into a thorn
bush and somebody stuffs a dead fish in
your mouth I do
yeah - I agree it's a one-for-one one I
would say a warrant only because I don't
want to be rude and say zero oh man I
don't even if I have gum after this oh
this is gonna be good here we go baby
steak I have high hopes for this one
Oh without the cheese yes double
stuffing a thing upon me by Cisco this
is stuff oh yeah good the steak is
really well done looks like really thin
cut very chewy it gets good but there's
nothing special about it it's just kind
of like you I'm gonna leave full
unsatisfied one is a four point one yeah
a little bit better I grew it up four
fives in my book three cuz it's pretty
good steak no - I'm gonna go for it no
move over other Bondi flavours before we
get to the final results I have a bonus
item Vietnamese coffee you'll pretty
much find this at any of enemies
restaurant and after my co-workers try
them we'll get to the results stronger
and it's very sweet correct it's awesome
oh it's so good it tastes very carefully
it tastes like someone melted dark
chocolate into a nice drink but with a
[ __ ] punch of caffeine
this is condensed milk really bitter
yeah I'm really sweet really strong but
also very like creamy yes yeah oh my god
me so [ __ ] up when I get back to my
desk it kind of tastes like a frosty
chug-chug smile smile Oh 5 out of 5 it's
really good almost perfect if not
perfect oh man it's tough though because
they're really all good I understand now
why this is happening why we're trying
to figure out the best one this is like
not your traditional subway that's for
sure it's like 100 percent better if I
had to choose one in a Vietnamese
restaurant out to steak I think the
steaks my favorite lastly I would
alternate between chicken and steak very
happily clerk for sure how they've work
I think that special is my favorite if I
had to choose one to eat for the rest of
my life I choose the peanut chicken
chicken pork and steak that's my whole
eternity upon me like any of those you
can't go wrong it's a slightly different
experience with each but they're all
delicious I like them all except for the
sardine so we all hate sardines yeah
don't eat sardines I just don't know why
bodies aren't more prevalent in the US
it's upsetting to me and it's hurtful
the three of us let's go we'll get three
sandwiches and we'll just nibble and
past nibble pass and it will pass like
shoes you don't have to bring two
friends or if you don't have any friends
just get through yourself and go make
some friends I'm not letting you take
these sandwiches away from okay I'm
going to finish them all there's getting
cotton or adult braces
[Laughter]